[Music]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the first time I
went to Europe I traveled by Steve
Carell said airplane julia louis-dreyfus
said cruise ship Larry King said land
bridge he's old yeah yeah a very old ah
100 million years ago my ideal judge my
ideal judge Bill O'Reilly said is a
strict constitutionalist Chris Matthews
said won't legislate from behind the
bench Donald Trump said doesn't know how
to make guacamole here's one I'll only
have sex if Kate Hudson said I'm in a
loving committed relationship Channing
Tatum said the mood is right Kim
Kardashian said the camera on my phone
is working
[Music]
my diet consists mostly of Ava Longoria
said fruits and vegetables
Rob Lowe said protein and grains chris
christie said dead and alive I've
covered it yeah pretty much everything
I would have made a great astronaut
because Natalie Portman said I have a
strong science background Jake Tapper
said I never get motion sickness Bernie
Sanders said I already know how to pee
in a suit when Blake Lively was
criticized for saying I have an L a face
and an Oakland booty
I thought JB Smoove said she's just
quoting a sir mix-a-lot song and a
Kendrick said it sounds a little
insensitive coming from a white person
Alan Greenspan said damn boo you ain't
lyin you got that badonkadonk so thick
you can see it from the front make it
clap for your man a to the Jay
because we have got a rasp oh yeah if I
ever make it to heaven the first thing
I'd say to God is Jennifer Lawrence said
thank you for a wonderful life sweet
Ron Howard said what does it all mean
Kanye West said please no autographs one
thing you can definitely say about me is
Russell Brand said I have my own
distinct personal style Wendy Williams
said I'm blunt and outspoken Mitch
McConnell said when boiled I make a
tasty soup my guess is that's all about
him looking like a turtle I would say in
yeah it's an odd boast but I think
that's an odd boat hey I'll never
forgive myself for Jason Sudeikis said
missing my brother's graduation Emma
Stone said once cheating on an algebra
test Larry King said telling the Romans
where Jesus was I
[Applause]
he's my god so he's a very old man
Muriel
and a rat yes whoo Jesus he's over there
you